مشاهدينا الى المتحدث الرسمي
للجنه الصليب الاحمر في افريقيا استاذه
اليمنى يعني بدايه كيف هي الصوره
الانسانيه من هناك وهل تواصلتم مع طرفي
النزاع لفتح ممر انساني خلال الهدنه خصوصا
وان الوضع الانساني او الصحي متردي جدا
هناك
[تصفيق]
ماساوي كما اشرتم وتزداد الامور سوءا مع
مرور ساعات في ظل استمرار العمليات
القتاليه كنا نهيب باستمرار
بفتح مسارات انسانيه من اجل تقديم المؤن
والوصول الى المستشفيات ومساعدتهم على
اعاده خطوط المياه والكهرباء
وكنا نفعل هذا الامر من خلال حوارات
ثنائيه ومن خلال الدبلوماسيه الانسانيه
لان الامر قد اصبح اكثر والحاحا ولا
نستطيع ان نشدد ما فيهم كفايه على اهميه
الضروره الوصول الى المستشفيات وسيارات
الاسعاف لاخلاء المصابين والجرحى
وكذلك لجمع الجثث التي لا تزال ملقاه في
الطرقات منذ عده ايام
سيده اليونا يعني كنا كنا نتابع قبل قليل
الصور من المستشفيات الواقع ماساوي وايضا
يعني ما رفضناه مع كل الزملاء هناك بان
هناك نقص فادح على مستوى الادويه على
مستوى تامين الاسعافات الاوليه والجثث
مرميه يعني في الشوارع والمستشفيات كيف
ستتعاملون مع هذا الواقع وكيف ستضغطون على
طرفي النزاع لتامين ممرات ولتامين وصول
الامدادات الصحيه اللازمه
وقبل كل شيء اننا بحاجه لقدره الوصول
ونفعل كل ما هو بوسعنا على كافه المستويات
من خلال الاجتماعات والمناقشات في الخرطوم
وفي اماكن اخرى
وتفعيل كل قناه ممكنه والسبيل ممكن من اجل
تامين الممرات الانسانيه من اجل ايصال
المساعدات التوقف في العمليه القتاليه ليس
من اجلنا بل من اجل المدنيين الذين لا
زالوا عالقين منذ خمسه ايام وقد نفدت منهم
المياه الغذائيه الوضع لا يمكن تحمله وهذا
التزام بموجب القانون الانساني الدولي
لكافه هؤلاء الاطراف المتحاربه ان يعملوا
على تامين هذا الحيز الانساني هو ان
يعملوا على معامله وان يعملوا على تقديم
المعامله اللائقه الانسانيه للاسرى
وبالنسبه لنا فنحن عبرنا عن استعدادنا
لتقديم الدعم
وهناك متطوعون من الهلال الاحمر السوداني
الذين عبروا عن عدم مقدرتهم للتحرك بسبب
اطلاق الرصاص في كل مكان يعني كنتم قد
اعربتم باكثر من بيان وباكثر من تصريح عن
عدم قدره الكوادر الامميه من التنقل داخل
شوارع الخرطوم وايضا بمناطق النزاع بسبب
النزاع الدائر اليوم يعني هل هناك امل
باستجابه من قبل الطرفين هل هناك تواصل
مباشر معهم يعني لاعلاء الشان الانساني عن
اي شان اخر
يجب عليهم فعله لان لان هناك حاجه انسانيه
ملحه ولا بدل الاطراف في المتحاربه ان
تنظر بهذه الحاجه بهذه بهذه الحاجه
الانسانيه لانها التزاما بموجب القانون
الانساني الدولي وجزء من اتفاقيه جنيف
ونحن بدورنا مستمرين في
مناشدتي كافه الاطراف بصفه منظمه انسانيه
وبقدر ما نستطيع ان نفعله هو ان نستمر في
الطلب والحاحي على الوضع الانساني
الماساوي هناك وبمجرد حصولنا على قدره
للوصول سوف نتصرف من اجل الاستجابه
للاحتياجات هناك
سي
ده المواد الطبيه خصوصا بعدما خرج العديد
من المستشفيات عن الخدمه
في الصعود واخر تحديدات رايناها عندما
تحدثنا عن عدد الوفيات
فالرقم يفوق 200 شخص عندما نتحدث عن
الجرحى فان الرقم اكثر من 1000 شخص
وبالنسبه للجثث
متزايده وقد يصعب علينا بشد ان نعطيكم
صوره دقيقه للوضع الانساني الان لاننا لن
نستطيع التحرك بحريه بالنسبه لنا وليتسنى
لنا التقييم الموقف
ومعرفه الارقام الدقيقه لابد لنا من
الوصول الى تلك الاماكن وفي هذه المرحله
يتعذر علينا فعل ذلك ولكن ما نراه ونسمعه
ان الوضع ما زال مستمرا في الاتجاه نحو
وصوره ماساويه وهناك اشخاص مفقودين وهذا
سؤال جيد للتحدث عنهم لان كافتها تلك
الجثث المرميه في الطرقات ما لم نعمل على
على تامين ازالتها بطريقه
تكرم وفات هؤلاء الاشخاص فان هناك واقع
ملح وهناك سنوات ايضا عاشها السودان ايضا
حتى مع الظل عن العمليات القتاليه التي
تدور هناك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات